Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and this week
on Doctor Who we got the grand tour of Coal
Hill School and a lot of teasers for the big
Danny Pink and Missy arcs.
There was also a nice shout out to River Song
and Gallifreyan Clara but I’ll talk more
cool references after my Top 5.
Quick Reminder, this week’s giveaway is
open now, all you have to do to enter is be
a subscriber and leave a comment on this video.
Careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven’t seen it.
But starting with Top 5 moments.
Give you just a sec…
and Number 5 - The Doctor is the new Caretaker
Capaldi said he thought the Doctor quite liked
being a caretaker just because it put his
endless knowledge to practical good use.
Yes his main mission was preparing a trap
for the Skovox Blitzer, but while he was doing
that he was also puttering around cleaning
spills and fixing electric boxes and such.
Plus it gave him the opportunity to show off.
One of the funniest scenes was when he poked
his head in Clara’s window and corrected
Jane Austen on the blackboard.
I haven’t listened to it but their is an
audio drama where the first doctor and jane
austen go on an adventure in 1814.
It’s called Frostfire.
It’s just the latest in the long list of
mundane jobs The Doctor really enjoys doing,
like being a Curator of a museum or a Physics
Teacher.
In the Doctor Who Extra for this episode they
stuck in a bunch of clips from episodes where
the Doctor worked at schools and other odd
jobs all the way back to the First Doctor.
I’ll list them all off during references.
Number 4 - Courtney Woods
This was Ellis George.
She was in Episode 1, even though she came
back and got to go on the TARDIS I don’t
know that this was a teaser for future companion.
I think it was just a small field trip like
when David Tennant took Peter Capaldi’s
character from Fires of Pompeii on the TARDIS.
I love that the Doctor has such a predisposition
for precocious young women.
Let that be a lesson to any ladies out there
wanting to be the next companion.Qualifications
include being really stubborn, casually dismissive
of danger and morbidly curious.
She also got River’s Famous “Spoilers”
Line which reminded me of her “Mel” regeneration
from Let’s Kill Hitler.
No I don’t think that was Mel, I just think
it was another wink at the audience.
Just like the story about the Doctor living
with Otters because of the fight with River.
I know there have been a lot of rumors about
Jenna Coleman leaving.
I actively tried to not consider that when
thinking about Courtney.
You could potentially see her scenes as the
series ‘test driving’ new companions.
I don’t think that’s what’s going on,
but you can’t help but think about it.
Number 3 - Clara Explains The Doctor To Danny
This was really cool because you find out
what Clara really thinks about her adventures
deep down inside.
The series tells a lot of parables and the
doctor and his companions get moments of reflection
all the time.
But most of the time it’s done under the
guise of humor.
Like when people get real with companions
about The Doctor they deflect a lot of tension.
So you don’t linger inside their brains
for too long.
It’s like Clara is trying to explain what
candy tastes like to someone who has no taste
buds.
Traveling with The Doctor is like the ultimate
fulfilment of your childhood delight.
Doctor Who can be a very cerebral show in
moments like this, which is why I’m digging
Capaldi’s Doctor so much.
He just spends equal amounts of time inside
his own head and being present in whatever
moment he’s in.
Whenever Jenna Coleman really decides to leave,
whether it be this year or next year.
I think we’ll get more of these big introspective
scenes, like she’s laying the groundwork
for her memoirs.
Like her version of There and Back Again,
with the role of Bilbo Baggins being played
by Clara Oswald.
Number 2 - Clara and The Doctor put on a Play
for Danny Pink
The big reveal was appropriately epic and
I love that they turned it into a school drama
production.
“Boyfriend Error” definitely one of the
best one liners from the episode.
They sweep the big curtain back and bam, the
TARDIS is there.
Like they’re a couple of magicians.
Which sounds even more funny after The Doctor’s
magician joke from last week’s episode.
I’ve never seen Doctor Who done as a stage
play before and I wasn’t a drama club geek
when I was in school, but this felt very visceral.
It also answered a lot of quesitons about
Danny Pink’s role.
Samuel Anderson called himself a companion
to the companion, so yes I think now that
the curtain has been pulled back.
He’ll spend more time on the TARDIS with
Clara.
What’s more interesting is his relationship
with The Doctor.
It seems like they’re both watching each
other.
The title of the episode was The Caretaker
and it felt like we’re supposed to think
Danny Pink and the Doctor feel like they’re
Clara’s Care taker.
In that they both feel like her care giver.
When Danny talked about The Doctor pushing
Clara too far it felt like foreshadowing for
something big.
It really turned me around on the episode,
the whole thing seemed like it was told from
The Doctor and Clara’s perspective, so when
Danny Pink learns about the doctor, you’re
thinking about it from The Doctor’s perspective.
But that last scene with him makes it feel
like the whole thing was being told from Danny’s
perspective.
Like the Doctor, not Danny will do something
really crazy and Danny will have to fix it.
Just rewatch the scene where Danny calls the
Doctor on being a Lord, and the moment when
he brings out the Doctor’s Rage.
and my number 1 moment - Missy is Back
Where are we is the big question.
The person greeting the policeman said there
was a range as if he could just take his pick
of what to call it.
All of the terms being references to where
you go after death.
There was The Afterlife, The Promised Land,
The Nethersphere.
It looked more like purgatory to me.
Like the policeman was in the waiting room
for the nethersphere.
Missy’s character is called the gatekeeper
of the nethersphere.
And when she did show up she looked very preoccupied.
As opposed to her previous appearances when
she was greeting new people with smiles and
tea.
It definitely makes her seem much more sinister
and now I’m wondering if she’s some sort
of cosmic entity.
That’s what we’re being led to believe,
like she is somehow the ruler of purgatory.
Some non-coporeal being.
Usually it’s times like that when there’s
a big twist and the character ends up being
an imposter.
It doesn’t seem like Missy is masquerading
as anything right now so I’m really hoping
we get to see her explain herself to another
character.
This policeman is one of the first characters
to question WTF is going on?
So I don’t think it will be too long before
we take the next step and someone asks Missy
Who Are You?
Let me know what your favorite moment was
and what do you think Danny meant when he
said The Doctor might push Clara too far?
While you think about that, here’s some
of the bigger references I spotted in the
episode.
Please add any you saw in the comments if
I don’t list them.
First up is all the Doctor’s jobs, over
the course of the 50 plus year history he’s
had just about every interesting job you can
imagine.
The most interesting being the Tom Baker Curator
reference from the 50th, all the deputized
law men he’s been and being an actual teacher,
not just a figurative one in the context of
the show.
When people talk about Doctor Who’s origins
it sounds a lot like the precursor of Mister
Rodgers In Space.
Like an educational show about History and
Science that also tells narrative stories.
So the Doctor has always been a teacher in
a meta context.
One of my favorite tennant teacher moments
was The Doctor Loves Physics.
Then There’s John Smith, the name the Doctor
used in Family of Blood
The River Song reference I already mentioned,
but I felt like when The Doctor said I used
to have a teacher just like you, he was referring
to Gallifreyan Clara.
I know everyone always wonders whether that
version of Clara became a Time Lord and I
don’t think she did.
It seems like if she were a teacher at the
Time Lord academy she’d have a better chance
of keeping an eye on him.
The Giant Chessboard felt a little ominous
but Chess has showed up all over Doctor Who’s
history.
There was a giant chessboard in the Tomb of
Rassilon that was designed to be a trap.
But you could view this as being foreshadowing
for a conflict with Missy.
Or a visual reference of the giant chessboard
from doctor who history.
The umbrage the Doctor takes when Danny Pink
calls him out for being a Time Lord is a nice
reminder of his troubled relationship with
them.
Those were some of the more fun nods, but
if you spotted any good Coal Hill references
from specific episodes write them in the comments.
Overall I gave the episode a B plus, they
nailed the montages but I felt like the pacing
between the first half of the episode and
the second half was a little uneven.
The opening Clara montage was brilliant and
I loved the music they set it to.
It reminds you of the many clara’s all doing
everything.
Like she has a supernatural level of energy
to match the doctor’s.
And the second big montage when Clara was
trying to watch the doctor while he was puttering
around the school as the caretaker.
That moment when Danny Pink sees the curtain
pulled back on the TARDIS is really when the
action stops short.
Like a record drop.
In the context of the story I understand why
that was there, the change in the pace is
supposed to make us feel uncomfortable because
the Doctor is no longer the alpha male in
the room and there’s still a lot we don’t
know about Danny Pink.
The stunts were all great, did anyone else
make the six million dollar man sound effects
when danny flipped over the skovox.
I don’t think they were making any special
references, but they way they filmed it looked
a little funny.
I know a lot of you mentioned you heard clockwork
sound effects during Danny and Clara’s dinner
date, like he might secretly be a clockwork
droid.
I don’t think that’s the case, but I supposed
it’s possible he has some special abilities.
He jumped about six feet in the air, so you’d
have to be pretty badass to pull
that off.
I was relieved to see Missy again too.
If that’s going to be the big arc of the
season I feel like not mentioning her for
weeks and weeks at a time and then just dumping
her on us would be terrible.
They are making the episode less serialized
this year, so I understand why they’re not
putting her in every episode.
It was a great episode, but I feel like based
on what I’ve read about next week, Kill
The Moon, that episode will be one of the
Fan Favorites from series 8.
I’m posting my bonus video next, so check
back in about 6 hours for that.
I’ve got a bunch of extra videos coming
this weekend, so I’m trying to get them
all out in a timely fashion without killing
myself.
The Q&A will post on Sunday, so you have a
ton of time to re-watch the episode and think
of some good Missy danny pink theories.
Right now click here for the bonus video and
click here for the Q&A.
I’ll update the annotations as soon as I
post them.
Thanks so much for watching, now let’s all
high five and go write our own doctor who
stage play.